[Laughter]
[Music]
Yan
in
[Music]
for
[Laughter]
[Music]
in
[Laughter]
[Music]
in
for
[Music]
[Laughter]
for
[Music]
in
may Allah untie any knots from our
tongues B for us our chest allow us to
speak the truth allow us to be alone
without the influence of Shan may Allah
allow us to be um leaders for the the
righteous may Allah allow us to be good
role models for men and bring people
back to the de of
Allah welcome back to the realist
podcast in the the three Muslims you
joined here with myself brother Ramy
over here on the right and brother Rakim
in the middle how you guys doing
aldah aldah doing good how you doing man
is is it live he was
yes everybody that's pressure live and
streaming 100 viewers right off the bat
may Allah bless you all for tuning in
brothers and sisters a lot of things
we're going to talk about today man so
you've been Muslim for how long I took
my shahada on the 8th of March 2021 at
4:31 p.m. I think yeah full you gonna be
that specific and then you're GNA say I
think I think no I think it it might
have been 432 I can't remember but it
was it was one of the two but so I've
been Ming for what like two years now
two years and a bit two years yeah so
you know we got to go over your rever
story right off the bat for any of the
new subscribers that don't know much
about your rever story if they don't
what are you guys doing I want to also
talk about a little bit of revert
struggles cuz you know being a a Muslim
parents aren't Muslim you still I'm
assuming you know close with your family
right so how you manage to go to omra
Bro without them finding out how you
manag to to Subhan Allah so we got to
talk about that I'm surey has a lot of
questions for you too bro so guys it's
going to be a juicy episode
inshallah so with that being said why
don't we start off with your rever story
for anyone that doesn't know much about
it so my rever the way I came to Islam
was it was through a debate with my
friend so throughout my whole life Allah
if I speak too fast tell me I'm Chinese
I speak kind of fast but so when Allah
bless me with Muslim friends I live in
Kum it's a part of the UK where there's
just hella like Bengali Somali and you
know whatnot so I was always surrounded
by Muslims and they would always give me
dawa but I would never you know I would
never absorb it I would never I was
ignorant to it you
know but then what happened was one day
I was arguing with my friend and he said
to me he was like William that was my
carean name he was like William if you
go go home and watch this video with the
scientific miracles of the Quran and we
had this whole argument we was like I
was like n I'm not going to watch it n
you're a donut for believing in God
that's Lally what I said to him and then
I went home and I watched the video but
I didn't watch the video to learn from
it I watched the video from an ignorant
and prideful perspective I watched it oh
I'm going to find the loophole in this
video I'm going to be like okay this
doesn't make sense and this doesn't make
sense but as we know Subhan Allah the
Quran is a perfect book there are no
flaws in the Quran so
the whole video made sense to me but I
was still for the pride I still said to
myself like Subhan Allah I can't make
that jump I'm an aist I'm a strong
atheist I can't do it and then I went on
a rabbit hole I started watching hella
videos like Dr zik and like like for
example I was trying to find another
loophole I said cool Evolution doesn't
tell with Islam so then I watched a
video Dr like Evolution and
then dinosaurs musty on dinosaurs and it
all just kind of made sense to me and
one thing a big influencing Factor was
me um researching up on the the
predictions of the Prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam because so many of them
are true and I thought to myself I was
like how can a book so full of Truth be
false because if there's all these
truths like the scientific Miracles all
these predictions and everything then
the Hellfire must be ruled then Allah
must be ruled the prophets must be ruled
does thatan
sense am yeah so then I was still full
of Pride um so I'd call my friends all
the time and be like tell me stories
about the prophet and my friend tson
he's the person that I took my shahada
with he um he would just tell me stories
about the prophet Ibrahim Prophet Eunice
all these Amazing Stories like the story
of the Zam Zam that's the first ever
story that I heard that's the first ever
Prophet story that I heard the story of
the Zam well so my belief my Iman was
already there but I was so full and
proud that I couldn't make the jump so
then I called my friend tson I was like
yo Taz like sorry TS um I'm ready to
become a Muslim but I can't make the
jump yet and he told me he was like just
ask God so I sat down in my mom's room
and then I said God if you're Allah if
you're real guide me bearing in mind the
car is that way and I'm looking that way
I was like I didn't know what I was
doing I was like God if you're real guid
I mean and I left at that and then a
week later I got a sign and I'll never
tell anyone that sign maybe like not
even my own mother maybe I might tell my
wife I might tell my kids I don't know
but that sign is between me and God and
ever ever since the sign happened my Ean
can never be broken and yeah that's
that's the story
really and then I can tell you another
story about how my name is Rakim um when
I took my shahada my name was originally
going to be ABD Rim I was like cool ABD
Rim you know merciful
Etc and then what happened was is I took
my shahada and then some guy came up to
me and he's like what's your name and I
was like Abdul Rahe but he thought I
said Abdul Rakim and he was like Rakim
and I was like yeah that's my name Rim
so yeah that's that's that's it really I
don't know I don't know if I rambled on
for too long but yeah no you're good is
that really the story yeah yeah I don't
tell a lot of people that I don't tell a
lot of people t3m exclusive
alhamdulillah okay
so guys I don't know what we got got to
do to get this this juicy story on man I
don't know if Rim is going to take like
a th000 likes 5,000 likes 10,000 likes
but we got to get him to to leak that
story man if it's personal listen if
it's personal these things are left
between you know you and Allah yeah yeah
but I'm I'm at the edge of my seat man I
gota I got to figure this out but it's
it's good to see that everyone has these
personal stories and these intimate
stories often times we think that it's
it's like a rational or logical thing
that's necessary and yes it is but many
times that isn't sufficient you you know
we need something a little bit more
emotional we need that spirituality
aspect of it and it's heavily undermined
a lot of times nowadays especially the
way that Muslims are raised
unfortunately so this being said how was
your experience after this reversion
until now what has changed since the
last podcast that we did with you about
a year ago I feel
like the our podcast was last year right
it was last year so
throughout I feel like when we done the
podcast I wasn't as developed as I am
islamically because you know back then I
still didn't know the you
know I still didn't know that um that's
just one example but I feel like from
now from that time period to the present
I feel like I've developed a lot in the
sense of I've learned so much and I've
been through a lot Allah has put me
through hardship which is obvious that's
obviously going to happen and I feel
like with those
experiences especially going umra I feel
like um umra changed my life but me
going especially going umra like
everything in my life and okay if I'm
going on a tangent tell me I just you
know I always go on tangents but you're
good bro no worries in go everything in
my life like I've just been thinking a
lot throughout this last year and I just
thought to myself everything in my life
has led up to this moment of Allah
guiding me so Allah has always been
there in my life and I came to that
realization like it's like three months
ago because every small action I've
taken in school and every small action
I've done and every time I've helped
someone out that's been good there for
me you know but a year ago I didn't know
that I thought oh God is you know I've
just found God but no you know he's
always been there for me I feel like I'm
waffling so much all my days but yeah
that's how I've kind of developed if
that makes
sense so you mentioned you mentioned
that there were some hardships that you
had to face that helped you develop yeah
is it too personal if I ask what kind of
hardships like generally speaking
hardships of you know grief you know the
loss of a loved one and loss of people
around me but when I look at it you know
from an Outsiders perspective and I
remove the emotion from it it was all
for their better you know because at the
end of the day yes go no no no no please
finish because at the end of the day um
even though I lost someone very dear to
me
that you
know that that only strengthened my Ean
you know the person wasn't Muslim but
that only strengthened my Ean at the and
at the end of the day the realization
that I came to is this is just the D you
know like anything that strengthens your
Eman anything that does anything for you
to get closer to Allah is a blessing you
know and that's that's what I mean by
went through hardship not like crazy
stuff I didn't like I didn't like climb
a mountain or something didn't like get
my legs chopped off but you know it was
more just Within Myself And Me
critically thinking about you know
situations and whatnot aldah yeah I had
um I had a very similar experience man
and I was already I was already
practicing at this time
aldah yeah so I I I got hit pretty hard
with with with something similar and I
was grieving hard man and I don't know
what it is but there's something about
that being in that state where all you
have is is is your trust in Allah like
you don't really have anything else like
you can't really eat much you can't
sleep much you know you wake up in a
shock whatever it is yeah you don't have
anyone except Allah you're you're so low
you're like Rock
Bottom really really builds up that that
trust alhamdulillah so it's I feel like
that's why I feel like that's why God
Allah put me in that situation because
like right now you know Allah says the
way you view him is how he is and right
now I view Allah as the most loving
person the most merciful person and the
the provider the protector you know what
I mean yeah and I wouldn't I don't think
I would be at this stage of my Islam
development if it wasn't from going
through that stage of grief because I've
never griefed before this is the first
time I've experienced it and it was it
was it was tough I'll be honest with you
because I didn't know how to cope I
didn't know what to do so I looked for
you know really bad stuff to I I looked
I coped in a very negative way but then
but I never found fulfillment it was I
only found fulfillment in Allah and
that's why the hardship was a blessing
yeah and it looks like uh it looks like
after the hardship there was some ease
when Allah 100 bless you with so why
don't you tell us about how that
happened so me going umra was so crazy
okay I had a dream that I went umra in
like I can't even remember but I had a
dream I went umra and I woke up and I
made a video I was like okay yo I just
had a dream I'm going umra this is my
umra
arc and
then the next week I made Dua I was like
Allah guide me to umra like Allah I'm
trying to go umra and then literally the
next week some guy messaged me and was
like you trying to go um and I was like
what yes are you
crazy what but going umra was one of the
crazy like the most profound experiences
I've ever felt like I not pity but I
feel sorry for the non-muslims that will
never be able to feel that the level of
Faith the level of Iman the level of
trust that I felt in omra because when
you see have you not been om by the way
yeah when you see the cab in front of
you it's kind of like everything that's
it you realize that this world is
temporary you realize that nothing
really matters and all that all of our
problems are just on this one rock
called the that Allah made and Allah's
testing us
on and the only thing that matters is
what's in front of you and that's the
Kaa and that's that's worshiping Allah
so that's how that you know it was it
was amazing but do you guys prefer
Medina or mea because I prefer
Medina bro I was I swear to God I was
just thinking about this I was just
thinking about how every every single
time someone goes to Mecca and Medina
they talk about how their experience was
in Mecca for me I felt like a weirdo for
like the last year or so because it was
always Medina that stood out the most it
was always Medina that made me cry the
most um but why don't why don't you talk
a bit about why you felt that
way okay me and my friend my friend's
mother um shout out Auntie FIA but she
told me that she teaches me Quran by the
way but she um she told me that when you
first see the ca I don't know how true
this is but she told me when you first
see the ca the first ever du you make
will come
true and obviously you know my parents
aren't Muslim and there's nothing more I
want for them to be Muslim so when I saw
the ca for the first time wait what was
the question again
Sor you're good man okay keep bro keep
rolling so when so when I was um when I
went to see the Caba for the first time
I made the Dua and bearing in mind I
haven't like I don't really get I don't
really cry I don't really shed tears I
do shed tears here and there I'm an
emotional person but I don't really cry
per se but when I first saw the CA and I
asked Allah to guide my parents to Islam
oh I couldn't hold it in that I couldn't
I just cried for like 30 minutes and
like it was hella awkward because there
was just hella people around me watching
me cry I just felt H St wow but yeah it
was amazing it was amazing I'm the
prophet's mosque bro it's actually so
amazing oh my gosh what about that what
about that stood out to you in Medina in
Medina nothing physically stood out to
me well obviously the the mosque is
Grand and all these but nothing it was
more of the um the spiritual side of it
because I felt so much peace and so much
fulfillment being you know in this being
present in Medina and being present
where the Prophet sallallahu alhi
wasallam was and especially in M Nei
which is you know the prophet's mosque
for anyone doesn't know
but it was just a city of Peace like I
can you can only explain it unless
you've been there you know because you
know when you go like when you go Mecca
like everyone's like it's like WWE
everyone's fighting to go to the ca
everyone's pulling each other you know
alhamdulillah this is how it is but when
you go to Medina it's kind of just like
everyone just lowers it down everyone's
just relaxed everyone's got a smile on
their face the food's nice people are
nice the weather's nice everyone's
praying you know so it was just amazing
and and I just met so many amazing
people like especially pakistanis I love
pakistanis once they saw me they would
always tell me oh are you from China and
I'm like yeah and they would just always
give me a gift like I've got I don't
know what my pouch is but in my pouch I
have this one compartment of all the
gifts that people these especially
pakistanis they gave me like they gave
me like TP they gave me qurans they gave
me everything just because you know I
was a Muslim and I was Chinese
it was just that Brotherhood that I
adored and that's that's one of the
reasons why I love Islam one of the
reasons one of the reasons why I'm so
proud to be a Muslim is because of the
Brotherhood at the end of the day I
don't think you can find this
Brotherhood anywhere unless like you're
in a tribe in like the village of China
you know
yeah bro speaking about this brotherhood
like it reminds me of the time that me
Ramy and anho we went to omra together
and I believe this was Ramy and an's
first omra MH it was earlier this year
in I think towards the beginning of
March when we went and I remember that
their experience was very similar
because when we went to Medina it was
nice you could take it at your own pace
there was no rush there was no crowds
and then when we went to mecah during
the Haram I don't even know what what
happened to my camera lgtv Community
hacked your camera
bro yeah I think it just like timed out
but yeah so you know in meca it was like
very hustle and bustle it was busy
everyone was pushing and shoving right
and their their experience from what I
remember it was kind of the same however
for me anytime anyone ask me that
question I always say meca and here's
why my first omra that I went to was I
believe two or three years ago and it
was during covid so everything was shut
down I'm talking at the Haram bro at the
main level where the ca is you're
probably going to have no more than like
30 people bro which is in to even
comprehend that now it's like impossible
bro and Subhan Allah Allah blessed me
with that being my first experience with
omra because I felt that that that real
experience around the ca during ta that
I I couldn't feel the the subsequent
times you know in the crowds so recently
me and anill went to omra I think about
a month ago two months ago and it was
the same experience as when we all went
together in February it was too crowded
it was two packed you know so Medina
definitely now I would say is is a
little bit more like spiritual for me
but before my first time Mecca was
amazing man were you able to touch the
black stone because you was like that
close to no so because it was Co they
had these red uh I think this little
fence around the cabba and you couldn't
even go past that wow yeah so so the
people that were like super like immuno
compromised people that were elderly
only they were allowed that close cuz
you know and we actually had social
distancing bro believe it or not when we
yeah bro it was wild it was mad and I
was like what is this everyone's wearing
face masks I think cuz you're not
supposed to wear anything stitched right
so a lot of people were wearing face
mask I think the scholars put out a fwa
there at that time it was like it's
permissible so it was a very different
time you know but if I had to tell you
my best experience it was definitely
that time but alhamdulillah arami how do
you think your experience was your first
time that we went in February do you
think Medina was definitely better yeah
so um it's it's funny because the first
time you went it was during covid the
first time I went I had Co so
yeah we were in Medina and um I started
to just get very sick and um it turns
out I had covid um but that aside like
aldah that that genuinely did not stop
it from being the greatest experience of
my life especially in Medina I don't
know what it is I think it's the fact
that Medina is the place where Islam was
established you know like the prophet
started his journey in Mecca he started
his mission he got his prophethood in
Mecca he started preaching in Mecca
um and obviously Mecca is is a beautiful
and and very very important place
islamically and it has my heart so I
don't want anyone to like think this is
some weird competition but my personal
experience was when I was in Medina I
was just I was balling my eyes out
because I I think it was the fact that
if we if we as an um were in the state
that the Muslims were in you know in
Medina towards the end of the life the
propham I I feel like we'd be amazing
you know if if every Muslim was like in
the State those Muslims were like before
the prophet wasam passed away or even
soon after once they got back together
regrouped and all that stuff I feel like
we'd be a lot better than we are right
now so I think that's what got to me and
it got me affected me so much that I
just kept walking around especially the
grave you know how in Medina they have
the graveyard that grave changed my life
yeah I was there and we buried I think
the first one I buried was actually a
kid Subhan Allah I was was fortunate
enough to be to to grab a hold of the
casket and be one of the the ones who
carried it and it was a kid uh so I it
it broke my heart and um I started
crying so much I was
saying I was crying so much and I was so
like kind of bewildered at the moment
but I started saying it wrong Subhan
Allah like that's how yeah I started
Subhan Allah that's how like just broken
I was but it was it was amazing
alhamdulillah it was just it was it was
so heartfelt it's an experence I'll
never forget when I first saw the Caba
on the other hand it was beautiful it
was
amazing but being there just reminded me
of kind of the mission of Islam you know
like being there it was it it felt
different it's like when the prophet was
here he was preaching he was working to
establish Islam and that's that's all I
could think about while I was there yeah
the first omra we went on as a group was
with uh brother wahab I am the Warner so
shout out to him Allah bless him
immensely for all he he's currently in
uh Saudia right now doing omra with far
and sneo for anyone that doesn't know so
yeah sneo bro they're literally doing
right now so accept their umra and Grant
all of their duas and allow us to
experience omra again in so I remember
this car ride that we had um when we
were in jeda bro I know this is about
you but this you got us so passionate
about rra and experiences you know but I
remember when we we landed in jeda bro
we were doing this train ride to to
Medina after the train ride we took a
taxi I remember just looking at Ramy
during the taxi ride and Ramy was just
in full like just presence bro just
looking around like oh that's where this
was that's where that was and he was
just in a Zone where he was just so
present I've never seen Ramy this
present at least in person and he was
just super present immersed and I
believe we were all sleep deprived cuz
you know long journey and all that and
wahab is just like do you guys want to
go to the Bak the graveyard next to the
prophet's musk uh in the morning to bury
the bodies I was like bro what are you
talking about bury the bodies cuz I've
been there but I don't know this and
he's like you know after fuder they
bring in a lot of bodies and we can
actually like carry them into the
graveyard and then you know dig and bury
I was like bro Subhan Allah it's amazing
we were all sleep deprived but we said
let's do it so when Rami brought that up
I remember like in that trip I believe
that was like the first biggest
spiritual experience if not the biggest
at least the first main one of that trip
and when we were you know bearing the
body subh all I could think of was just
how temporary this life is nothing
matters we're all going to end up in the
same clothing
bro yeahh Allah um seeing that grave
being at janat was it jatu Baki janak
yeah being at janaki was so profound
because when they're carrying all of the
bodies in you literally think I was
thinking to myself the whole time the T
guys was speaking in my ear and he was
saying how you know the men are buried
with one stone women are buried with two
stones I wasn't even listening to what
you were saying all I could think to
myself was like wow these people there's
no more repentance there's no more
worshiping there's nothing that's the
grave and they're either going through
the most amount of pain and torture and
torment of their entire life or they're
going through one of the most beautiful
experiences of you know a warm hug
Subhan Allah it changed my life like it
was
crazy subh Allah man Subhan I believe
bro I think I went on an Instagram pick
and it was like you and rra and then
some some brother commented like bro
how'd your parents not find out and
you're like I told them I went to
Morocco yeah that's yeah what's it um so
I was going to I was meant to I went
there with my friend his name's Imran
shout out Imran if you're watching this
big shout out to Imran but he um so we
was gonna shave our heads yeah but then
my mom so I went holiday I was telling
my mom was going holiday and she was
like where you going and she was asking
hella questions and I was like Oh my
days Mom I'm going to Morocco cuz if I
told her I was going to Saudi she would
hide my passport cuz you know when I
first converted to Islam my mom hid my
passport cuz she thought I was going to
like join like Isis or something wa you
told her no no no no well she kind of
knew cuz she knew I was praying this is
off like freshly like fresh fresh this
is before this I got the own and what oh
look at look at Amy's
cat but um yes if I was like oh I'm
going to Saudi she's just gonna hide my
passport and I just can't go so I was
like oh I'm going Morocco but I messed
up I messed up so badly because um at
the border my mom M was like sent me a
picture of the airport and I was in
Jordan and I sent a picture of Jordan
and she was like that's not Morocco and
I was like Mom it is but yeah that's how
I got away with it so I couldn't shave
my head because if I came back with a
freshly shaven bold head my mom would
have be like oh you was not in Morocco
you was in you was in Saudi so I was
that yeah she would have clocked it real
quick bro 100% 100 how do okay so how do
you think if it's not too much of a
personal question how do your parents
differ in how they would kind of
approach you being a Muslim your dad
versus your mom my father is a very
traditional man you know my my father
you know
my my mom is more acceptive of me being
Muslim by the way my mom has accepted me
now as a Muslim you know that have I
told you that aldah no going to that
story bro yeah well basically um to make
a long story
short we were just chilling in our room
but I was walked into my mom's room one
day and she'd come back home from
holiday and she looked at me she was
like I know you're Muslim and I was like
what do you mean she was like I know
you're Muslim and I was like she was
like look at me in the eyes and tell me
you're not and I can't lie to my mom's
face so I was like yeah I'm a Muslim and
she was like what are you going to do
now and I was like I don't know I'm
going to be the same I just believe in
God and she was like okay and she just
carried over but my father if my father
was to find out I can't lie it would be
a very long day very very long day but
he's very traditional but I don't blame
him because all that he's been fed his
fruits of life and religion have been
terrorism and 911 and the Taliban and
Afghanistan you understand so I can
never blame him for that the only way
that I could maybe show him you know the
beauty of the religion is through my own
actions and that's what I'm trying to
slowly do I don't really speak to my
father but when I do speak to him I'll
slip in like oh do you believe in God
like I had a conversation with him two
months ago and I asked him oh do you
believe in God and he was like I believe
in God but I don't know and I was like
how do you not know look at the trees
look at how perfect this cycle of life
is look how perfect everything is we
have everything in you know perfect
Unity it's it can't be a coincidence and
he just he just stayed silent and just
smoking a cigarette but that's yeah
that's how they differ because my dad's
not very accepting of this new like
lgbtq and
what you know it's uh it's it's a
phenomenon that I'm I'm I'm seeing and
I'm recognizing a lot that the younger
generation is more prone to accepting
Islam for very reasons and the older
generation is still scared for various
reasons I think all of it has to do with
the social conditioning at the time our
generation grew up especially the mo
like the most recent generation grew up
with a um this this this feeling of you
don't want to be um you know divisive
with people you don't want to uh you
know uh kick people out or make them
feel unwanted B on the basis of religion
or ethnicity or whatever um and I think
it's because they got super liberal but
the generation before that
their religion was kind of taken away
from them they were forced to assimilate
with the people with the culture and
they lost a big touch because you know
atheism back then was really big and it
was powerful to a lot of people because
they thought it was oh it's science it
must be the truth and then the whole
thing on the war and Terror happened so
you know religion was really just ripped
away from our parent generation
unfortunately and and their parents
generation maybe even worse so with
everything that's happening in um in in
I don't want to say anything that would
you know contribute to any Shadow band
on our Channel
but uh with everything that's happening
there you know what was it like for you
as a rever seeing a lot of other people
start to accept Islam because of the the
the tawa and the belief and and the
Beautiful words of the people over there
despite what they're going
through it's amazing it is honestly
amazing because when you think about it
there's so much there's a beauty of the
conflict there is a beauty of what's
Happening can I say the word I'm not
trying to get you Shadow
BN the word is but whatever it is try
and substitute it there's a beauty of
what's going on in Pizza time does that
make sense there's a beauty of what's
going on in that country because number
one everyone that's dying is going Jenna
you know everyone that's dying the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam said
if someone dies as a
mar um all the pain they feel is the
bite of the incense you know yeah so
that's the first beat of the second beat
of it was Allah this happened Allah
wrote this Allah is making this conflict
happen you know and an effect of it is
so beautiful so many people are learning
about the religion I work in an Islamic
shop in East London and the amount of
white people black people Hispanic
people that come in and there they say
to me oh um I want to learn about the
religion and I ask them why and they say
because the conflict abroad has peaked
my interest wow they don't really say
that they go like oh because I saw this
video but what's pushing these people
towards Islam is the level of faith that
the people in the country have you know
because when you look at these videos
there's so much suffering and there so
much pain but yet they're still
persevering and I feel like that's a
lesson that we could all take because at
the end of the day they are in a
considerably worse situation than we are
in physically yeah so I feel like every
time we look at life we should look at
it with gratitude and happiness you know
that's a very beautiful Point man and
you know Subhan Allah
it's like every few months it just hits
me again that mannerisms and character
are both the most important thing when
when giving daa and if you look at just
recent history you know it I it becomes
more evident that Muslims in Islam are
just so beautiful that they have to work
overtime to make us look bad like the
whole war on terror thing really like
shot our image down and then when the
World Cup went to Qatar everybody loved
Qatar they tried so hard look bad for
this with workers and this with lgtv and
all these rights and and they just ended
up looking better um even people like
and I'm sure he had his own reasons but
even people like Piers Morgan were you
know defending them back then and what's
happening now in in you know abroad can
I can I ask you a question yeah go for
it so obviously I don't look visibly
Muslim you know so how is it like
growing up as a visible Muslim if that
Mak sense I said that question so bad
but yeah no no no worries it's a good
question um I think it's weird because
when you say looking Arab is looking
visibly Muslim because people correlate
you know being Arab with being Muslim I
don't people didn't know what I was
growing up they couldn't tell if I was
Auto Hispanic or what i i people thought
I was I was Spanish for a long
time wow you do not like Spanish yeah I
know but I mean I kind of see the
resemblance bro not gonna lie Chad what
do you think do you think uh you see a
resemblance or no my my experience and
and guys if you if we have time at the
end in we'll do like quick live Q&A CU a
lot of people are asking questions on
the chat questions that even I myself
are are wondering like for example what
does your dad believe you know or what
was most of your family you know kind of
from in in religious obligations but
before that I wanted to say that growing
up and this is kind of you know sad to
admit but it shows the state of the um
my experience being a born Muslim
visible Muslim I've had more FNA from
Muslims than kufar bro Subhan Allah
because where I was from now not my
family but where I was raised in the
schools and everything bro there was so
much Division and
tribalism and loyalty to like where
you're from in terms of your country and
stuff like that that they wouldn't even
put those things past you bro they would
just have their own clicks it wasn't
like um like everyone was together
regardless of you know the color of
their skin however the older that I got
like when I went to UNI and and being
around Muslims nowadays Muslims nowadays
are completely different bro than like
10 years ago 15 years ago and I couldn't
help but Wonder like if I was in high
school or middle school and these kids
for example wouldn't be friends with me
because they're Pakistani and I'm
Bengali and I would wonder like it's not
their fault cuz I'm sure they're just
doing what their parents fed them what
their parents taught them you know that
you have to hold on to your heritage and
culture even if it means you know you
see somebody that's non- Pakistani in a
different way and that was my experience
growing up that I always felt kind of
outcasted from a lot of Muslims despite
being a Muslim and with the kufar I
never really had that much of a bad
experience if anything I've had a
experience I know you know we have our F
and in the west growing up but when when
kufar see you bro if you're Unapologetic
about your Muslim identity and you have
you know as Rami was saying the manners
and character which is absolutely
important bro we did an episode by the
way with Dr sail Ahmed which is going to
drop soon and we just went in on
character and akl but when we were
looking at that bro if you're
Unapologetic about it they will respect
you if you have to tell them you know I
work respectfully you know I got to take
five minutes away to pray you know
during the day they're going to respect
that I've only found that when you're
shy about these things that's when
you're going to get FNA but if you're
open about it and you're respectful and
you're professional about it they can't
help but respect you because you say no
when everyone goes out to drink and you
don't you know you don't want to
participate on that you don't want to
buy something that has pork in it for
your co-workers they're going to respect
these things Subhan
Allah yeah absolutely true and that's
why in Islam you know like the prophet
he was very Stern on on Islam to the
point where the
people um of qu they said listen we'll
just make you a king we'll make you King
just you know stop with XY Z and he said
if you put the sun in my right hand and
the Moon in my left hand I would not
abandon this Mission so you know we
small very we we s we Face very small
cases of this like you know Hey listen
if you're going to have to pray every
day then you know I have to cut your
hours or I have to pay you less or I
have to kick you off the team or you're
going to get fired or whatever do
it listen you firing me is better than
Allah firing me you know on hell so me
I've got a I've got um an experience
with that because like I said I work in
an Islamic shop right right now Allah's
blessed me like I literally get paid to
pray Allah Allah's blessed me so much
but before that I got a job offer like a
really really good job offer I'm telling
you like bro was crazy I was going to be
like with like you know like the
football of Harry Kane yeah I was going
to be like working with Harry Kane and
like this hella footballers but then it
would involve alcohol and like going
clubbing and like helping out in clubs
and whatnot so I said to myself I can't
do it I'm a Muslim and literally the
next week I got blessed with this
Islamic job where I get paid to pray
Allah is Lally the greatest
alhamdulillah aming Allah is the
greatest may can we take a break I need
to go toilet yeah of
course
problem I think this would be a great
time for us to talk about message that
we've been talking about in the group
chat bro which is you know with
everything that's going on in
Philistine why are Muslims so caught up
in Petty matters you know even our
experience with with uh she omaran in
person when we were there we were
talking about a lot of different things
man and you know when you meet someone
in person it's different than when you
meet them in camera you know a lot of
things they can't fake in person right
yeah and I remember Subhan Allah despite
all the FNA that's going on right now in
the car ride when we were just talking
to him he didn't mention ill about any
brother or sister there was no
backbiting in the entire time it was
just positive it was United and it
showed me like Why can't Muslims do this
soami why do you think today when
there's all this stuff going on that we
need to focus on that a lot of Muslims
are too caught up in these
things it's a very good question they I
think all of them get caught up in
different things for different reasons I
think that some people are given a
distorted version of Islam and for
whatever reason they believe it they
fall into this this weird um almost
satanic thought that the more strict you
are the better or the you know the more
strict you are the more religious you
are or something like that other people
are on the opposite end they're too
they're too liberal so anyone who they
think is too strict they're going to
attack them so you have those two
extremes and then you have the you know
um the personal issues the jealousy the
bickering the back biting the slander
the
for whatever reason and at the end of
the day the common denominator with all
of them is they they they lack
understanding islamically and what that
lack of understanding is is with what
Unity really means and what Unity
doesn't mean so unity in Islam means
that we unite on the worship of one God
Alone the prophet being his messenger
the Quran being the Revelation that he
sent with the prophet for us to follow
and Islam being our Dean
anything that falls within you know
valid points of contention difference of
opinion there is not worth bickering
over whether it is in and your your
actual like physical practice of the
religion uh the rulings or whether it's
in a there are some Scholars even like
Au Scholars who believed uh that
Hellfire comes to an end despite Allah
is saying many times that they will be
in there forever what does this actually
mean it's forever till the end of of
time or forever like until there's no
end so therefore it's actually like
forever or is it for as long as hell
exists and then Allah you know like like
it
really is a uh there's a minor opinion
that says that it'll come to an end so
you have some people that will take
others who have that opinion and call
them uh deviant but there are some
within their their own kind of uh
framework of a who are Authority that
will uh kind of have the same opinion
like um I don't want to go too deep into
it yeah because I know I'm going to step
on some people's toes but if there's a
valid point of contention then you
cannot be mad about it if a great
scholar in the past held his opinion you
can't really be mad about it you can
disagree with it but to say someone is
is deviant or misguided or uh causing
some kind of b or corruption or whatever
like would you say that same exact
wording about this great scholar who
believed in that exact same thing so I
think people have become way too
divisive and have strayed away from the
AY in the Quran where Allah he says hold
on to the Rope of Allah altogether and
do not become
divided yeah Shea was going in on that
bro in the the podcast we did with
Muhammed hijab and it's absolutely true
bro there's everyone's becoming
sectarian and what Ami is saying about
these valid you know that's fine we're
not saying you know have difference in
opinion and things that are clearcut
right yes you'll find Scholars today
that are going to say you know the
alphab movement is permissible you know
getting a r about mortgage is
permissible you're going to get all that
that's fine we don't that's not the
difference in opinion we're talking
about we're talking about valid
difference in opinion you're going to
hold this against your brother and
there's people that are getting deleted
right now in Philistine and you're going
to put that over what's going on you're
going to put that emphasis and energy
into that instead of actually doing
something Subhan Allah so this being
said before we go back into the stream
about brother Rakim what are things that
brothers and sisters can do now the the
ones that are wondering you know what
can we do to
support um make du okay go on to that
make du the most powerful thing like I
said remember that story I said about
omra where I just asked God God Allah
guide me to omra and he brought me there
like in like two weeks you remember that
story I said where I was like Allah
guide me to Islam and he brought me to
Islam the next week the most powerful
thing that a Muslim can do is make Dua
I've made Dua for so many things I've
come true alhamdulillah I'm trying to
say if you really want to help festine
cool go to protest yeah that does help
go to you know posting yeah it does help
at the end of the day the only thing
that can the only entity that can
actually change something is allaha if
you're waking up in the morning pray
Allah please Bless the people of
Palestine Allah bless the people of Gaza
Allah bless people Al you know that's
the best thing that you can do if that
makes sense I don't know yeah absolutely
and it's it's it's it's it's one of the
things that Allah says in the Quran that
Allah will not change the condition of
people until they change what's within
themselves and what you were saying
reminds me of how it's one of the tricks
ofan you know when we try to make Toba
we think you know why would Allah
forgive you you you're so horrible
you've done XYZ but it's like that
thought in and of itself that thinking
your sins are above Allah's Rah it's un
Islamic it's probably Haram at the most
and un Islamic at the least we shouldn't
think that way of Allah think that
little of Allah and even when we want
something we think that why would Allah
answer our Dua it's a trick of Shan
don't you think yeah 100%
I want to go a little bit deeper into
into the DU so they they they first
first and foremost du is the weapon of
the believer and Dua is something that
we should all start with not only should
we make Dua but we should know that
Allah is going to accept it and we
should basically Envision we should
physically Envision in our own minds or
I should say literally Envision in our
own minds falline being free by the of
Allah that's something that we should
believe will happen with utmost
certainty uh and make du for it but
similar to how you know after you made
Dua Allah gave you the opportunity you
you had to get yourself up get ready
pack Travel do and all that stuff hide
it from your parents you know all that
stuff the same way you had to take those
actions there are things that we have to
do the people in in ftin they have a
right over us we actually have an
obligation towards them and to towards
the Wagers in China and towards all the
other Muslims who are suffering around
the entire world we have an obligation
and if we don't fulfill it we're against
our own so now the question is how do
wefill
it no worries bro so I was I was just
I'll summarize quickly in it really
depends on the topic at hand you really
have to understand the situation you're
dealing with and maybe you would deal
with both situations differently Allah
at the end of the day we see there's
beginning to be a shift there there's
being there's pressure that's being put
onto the
occupational State there and that didn't
just happen in a vacuum that happened
alhamdulillah yes by the will of allaha
through the actions of the people
through the actions of of the Muslims
and you know the good-hearted people who
are bringing the truth to light here and
we need to keep pushing and keep
doubling down on this so everybody
should be um pressuring their own
governments their own MPS at my Masjid
the IM asked who wrote to our MP so
so and people put up their hands he's
like how many how many of you did he
respond to did he respond to anyone
everyone put their hands down because
he's not responding to anyone but this
is the pressure that we need to keep
putting through videos through actions
through protests through whatever before
Justin trudo couldn't even say the word
cease fire now he said that Israel needs
to stop and and and and restrain
themselves as much as possible because
the world is watching like it doesn't
get much more specific especially from
someone like Trudeau because he loves
being passive it doesn't get more
specific than that there the UN just
passed a resolution calling for a
ceasefire many countries are working to
Aid festine and also I just said a word
by the way that I think he's gonna get
everything kind of buzz okay I I'll say
a um a humanitarian pause like Trudeau
always says but long story short you
need to work to actually make some kind
of political change and that comes
through one educating people exposing
the truth two calling for some kind of
action to be done done and then getting
enough people to back that action both
socially and on the political level the
the members of parliament and Congress
and the the ambassadors and all these
people the politicians to get them to
back it and it's unfortunate but if
there are some Muslims who are rich
enough maybe they could work to Lobby
just like you know the zionists have
been lobbying a certain people a certain
amount of people politicians and uh that
might help as
well just just to add address that quick
question from Brother Hamza for the
Super
Chat will this live be uploaded on the
main Channel yes so all of our live
streams after the live streams are
concluded you go to our main Channel
inshallah and you will find that uh
click on the live tab or go down to uh
new live streams inah and guys if you
want us to do like a quick live Q&A at
the end of this with brother Rakim you
know any questions that I'm sure y'all
have been ready to ask for a long time
we can we can hit it
up but going back to this let's talk
about your parents bro bro what are
their religious views if they have any
my parents
um they're very spiritual they're
Catholic on paper on paper they're
Catholic but that was only to get me and
my little sister into the best school in
the area but when it comes to what they
actually believe in they're very
spiritual so in China what we do may
Allah forgive all of them is they um
they worship the ancestors because they
believe that they're an ancestral power
and they're going to help them Reach
fortune and what
so a lot of the time um a lot of the
time like you walking around the streets
of China and people just be burning
money because they burn money for the
people in the afterlife but what I would
say about my that's my parents belief
they're very ancestral my extended
family's belief and this and I'm
speaking for a lot of Chinese people is
money because a lot of Chinese people
worship money when you you know how if I
was to approach you I would say salamu
alikum and that means salamu alayum
means may peace be with you in China you
don't sayam alikum you say like I hope
you get more money like you get it like
there in China the religion is money and
you know it's just really backwards but
that's my family's religious Point of
View kind
ofh Allah I didn't know that I heard a
lot of things I didn't know that Allah I
heard that the people are so kind of
detached from one another that somebody
could be you know hit by a car and
they'll just be sitting there for like
an hour everyone will be walking by
nobody will
people in ch they just care about
themselves and I'm not speaking for I'm
not generalizing all Chinese people
obviously like my auntie is one of the
loveliest woman you'll ever meet in you
do meet her but a lot of the people that
all you know absorbed in their own lives
and they all because in China it's so
competitive everything in China is so
competitive there's so many people if
you want to make money you have to work
10 times harder than everyone else so
you can't afford to you know to sleep or
even rest for a minute extra than you
need be you know so that's why but when
I yeah when and that's what's that's
what amazed me about Islam because this
is linking back to the Brotherhood in
China I've only ever been the only
Chinese person if okay wait I've only
ever
been throughout my whole life in school
I was the only Chinese kid in school you
get what I'm trying to say yeah I never
felt that obviously I had friends around
me but I never felt that Brotherhood
with people and especially when I go
back to China there's no Brotherhood
everyone just Minds their own business
so when I joined Islam you know the
Brotherhood that I felt was so intense
and so amazing I mean that you know I
just I loved it and I fell in love with
the religion even more and even deeper
than I was initially
Allah how so what what when you say that
these are the things that stood out to
you could you be more specific what was
it specifically about the Brotherhood
what would people say to each other what
would people do for each other that
stood out it was the little thing like
even someone saying Alum to me that was
that little thing was so beautiful to me
because at the end of the day they don't
know who I am they don't know if they
don't know if you know I'm a murderer
they don't know if I'm this or that they
just know that I'm Muslim and we all
they know is that we believe in the same
God and because due to that fact we are
brothers you know and that's that's the
Baseline of it going more into it it's
when I cuz on my first Ramadan for if T
I would just eat crisps cuz I just
couldn't eat like I couldn't cook
anything or order anything so I just eat
crisps and I made a video about it and
the amount of people that would call me
people that don't even know my favorite
color they don't even know my favorite
person they don't know where I live they
know where I'm from they would message
me be like yo my mom's telling you to
come around and I'll be like why why are
you being so nice to me I had a bit of
imposter syndrome for a little bit but I
was like why are these people being so
nice to me I don't deserve all this love
but then when you think about it it's
just the Brotherhood and it's the
religion that guides everyone together
into this like into Unity if that makes
sense but yeah that's I feel I it but
yeah Subhan Allah bro this is a it's a
wonderful time to give the brothers and
sisters watching a reminder to look out
for the reverts you know cuz in Ramadan
and Aid they don't have family
necessarily that are practicing Islam
they don't have their community and many
times you know we know Shan comes for
the lone believer right so we don't want
them to feel isolated so we got to look
out for them this you know what you were
saying bro about the Brotherhood I was
in a taxi with anill headed to uh the
Haram and bro there was a random guy
that came CUA I think Miller bless the
brother and Miller forgive me if I'm
wrong but I think the brother couldn't
afford a cab or something so he was just
like you know can I hop in with you guys
me and an were like bro come in there's
an extra seat the the the fair is going
to be the same whether you come in the
seat or not so he hopped in and bro 5
minutes in we were talking about the
deepest most intimate things about our
lives and Islam and it was getting so
and we just for a sec and and me and
just looked at each other we're like bro
without Islam there's no way we would
have this level of connection with this
brother this quickly than anything else
cuz you know with the Kfar everyone's
just minding their own business you know
what I mean and this brother looked at
us too he's like bro Subhan Allah like
this was meant to be you
know Allah is a great yeah alhamdulillah
and you know I I I watched a video
recently of uh I don't know who the man
is so if someone knows please put it in
the comments but he was talking about
his experience in that place we were
just speaking about um I can't exactly
say um and also on the other side you
know the the is is not real
basically when he was when he was there
they were saying
listen the Arab quarters don't go there
they're going to do this to you they're
going to you it's very dangerous don't
go there so he he and his friends were
like we're going to go so they went and
they see an an an an Arab there you know
scary they see an Arab and the guy's
like are you um are you yahi like are
you the ethnicity of the people of
Judaism I don't want to say the word and
get demonetized but you know and then
the guy was like yeah and he's like come
come sit come sit he pulled out two
chairs he sat them down I think on some
tea or something like was talking and
the guy had such a beautiful experience
and I think that continued to like other
places and and that he went to there in
that area but it's like there's a
propaganda what people say about us and
then there's this we really are what we
really think what we really believe and
Subhan Allah this is a random note but I
was thinking about it yesterday and I
just want to I just want to say it I
know it's a bit off topic um but there's
also a level to this that's very
hypocritical from the opposing side the
people that say we're we're barbaric or
whatever when you when you ask them what
they don't like about like Islam they'll
say things like you know sh capital
punishment uh you off
people you know you'll you'll do bar R
things and cut people up and like all
these horrible things whatever so offing
people lying whatever they think we do
women are oppressed yeah all these
things so we you know we ask them you
know so what do you do to combat this
how do you stop us from implementing
Sharia you know and what do they do to
stop us from implementing Sharia they
off all of us they attack our nation
steal our wealth then they lie about it
in the media and say that we had weapons
of mass destruction it's like so to stop
us from offing people and doing these
things you come and you off us first
like does that really make sense it's
it's it's it's yeah as ye says it's
oppression of of the the top the highest
level did you have a perception of that
before Islam versus now not really but
reason being because I was surrounded by
Muslims Allah bless me you know with a
lot of Muslim friends so I saw the
Beauty and the beauty and the
characteristics you know I saw the
beauty in you know the way a way a
Muslim acted and this and that I didn't
see the terrorism side because obviously
in school you're going to make jokes if
your friends like oh you're a terrorist
you're terrorist but then they would
just tell me that no we're not
terrorists in in the in the Islam means
peace and it's Haram to if you kill an
individual it's like killing every
single human being on the planet Earth
so I never really had that preconception
not like my father or not like my mother
you
know yeah it was blessed but what I was
going to say is um I think that the
media portrays Islam like that because
Islam is such a big threat because if
anyone was to look at Islam from an
biased un prideful perspective they
would see the light in it and they would
see the truth in it but let's say the
majority of people come to Islam then
there's no more Banks the banks will
collapse and you know you know charity
and Islam kind of goes kind of not
completely but kind of goes against a
capitalist society and that's what
absolutely the elites need to make money
the elites just want to make money the
people just want to make money in this
world if you don't have a moral compass
which a lot of these rich people don't
you just want money and Islam completely
goes against Reba you know all these
inhumane practices that are going on in
order to make F so yeah that's why I
think there's so much propaganda and
there's so much there's so many negative
seeds and connotations about Islam
spreaded and spreaded through the media
because they need to make sure that you
know no one turns Muslim yeah and on top
of that I think they know as a whole
like since Islam has attracted so many
people so easily
they know that it's it's it's not just a
threat in the sense that it's a threat
to their capitalism or their system or
the or whatever it's it's a threat to uh
their power and I think that is the
scariest thing for them that's why they
put is not real right there in the
middle um and even Joe Biden said if it
didn't exist we'd have to invent one to
secure the national interests of America
what that looks like is if they restrict
oil to us like King facel did then we're
done we're
screwed uh so what they did was they put
you know a long time ago 75 years ago
they put somebody there um to to control
the the the area they fed them with all
these uh these these bombs and these uh
this military technology and they
couldn't feed them with the men because
all them are pan animous cowards over
there but they gave them military
advancements the money the whatever and
uh they're making deals with the people
that are there but when they first like
conquered that area after World War I
they uh divided it up because they knew
that if they join together if they come
together these people will really be a
threat especially since they hold the
oil imagine this is all one place and
the one ruler decides you're not getting
any oil from us they one power you can't
exactly just invade you can't exactly
just go go fight them and they control
what our entire country freaking runs on
at this point that's the biggest threat
to them so that's why they make all
these moves even I know I'm going off on
a tangent even like something as small
and people need to be politically aware
even something as small as Joe Biden
going to is not real going there and
physically being there is huge people do
that when they want to talk one-on-one
with the leader without any like you
know hackers intercepting the meeting or
whatever you know but the real reason he
did that is because if any of the other
nations decided to attack in any
capacity it would have been seen as a as
an attempt on the the the president
and then all of a sudden you're going
against all of NATO so like there there
are so many things that they do just to
try and keep some kind of control
dominance and Order over there it's it's
very sad but alhamdulillah they're
losing the media War to bring it back to
the point people are seeing what Muslims
are like What Muslim nations are like
like with the world war not the world
war sorry the World Cup um inar with the
people in in in fistin and how they're
acting how they're behaving even the the
Palestinians on this and having people
like Muhammad hijab and um basam YF and
people speaking out for the C
is a is is a huge light I think for
these people alhamdulillah why do you
think saudi's not there anything can we
talk about that is that like make you
lose
money why do you think Saudi Arabia is
not doing anything because I'm not
educated enough to well nothing's gonna
happen to our Channel if we talk about
that so that like that doesn't matter um
other than that Allah I don't know but
what I will say is I
the I don't think they really man listen
I don't know for sure at the end of the
day what I do know is they they seem to
be prioritizing some kind of political
relationship than the the lives of the
Muslims I think I can say that with with
a fair amount of confidence they don't
seem to really care about the people
that are suffering there they seem to
just care about how their own people
will perceive them and if they didn't
say anything their own people would
would would not accept it so what it
seemed what seems to be the case Allah
it seems to be the case is that they
said that we're going to stop all
negotiations until XYZ happens for the
people the Muslims there and then they
still continue negotiations afterwards
that is at least the what the president
of the US and and and the president of
is not real
said and it's not just that country bro
it's many countries many most majority
countries Unfortunately today you know
but M allow us to reunite on the
hu this is random but I want I want to
try something Mac just like apple just
updated the laptop to give like these
little like things that pop up I don't
know when I put a thumbs up is that does
it jump up no no this is what I'm
talking about let me get it because it
popped up on my screen I don't know
where it came from but this
thing what just now yeah love there's
love hearts coming up bro yeah I don't
this just popped on the screen randomly
I didn't put it up there it just jumped
up there so I was like what's going
what's trying to make the episode a
little spicy now cool BR but uh let's
get let's get back on the Q&A uh guys
you know any important questions
anything you guys really want to know we
got a party over here on the right so uh
atalia
asks do you have difficulty about food
when you revert especially when eating
with your family by the way hope your
parents get hi too I mean what's what's
hi guidan aanan um when it comes to food
not really yeah they do eat like you
know pork and whatnot but I don't really
eat with my parents I can't really
describe it like my parents I
don't okay I don't live with my parents
my parents live in like they're not I
don't live with them so alhamdulillah
Allah's blessed me with that so you have
your own sp or you live with like
roommates I live I live with my siblings
my two sisters but so that they and they
fully accept me being a
Muslim recently they they used to not
until like last are they older than you
or younger uh one's older one's younger
oh okay yeah I'm the middle child but so
yeah I'll tell you I'll tell you a story
my my oldest sister she wasn't the
biggest fan of me being Muslim because
of the way it affected my family Dynamic
if you know what I mean but then Subhan
Allah like last month I was just sitting
with her and the notification came up my
phone it was ass time and she was like
oh go pray Assad so she literally
doesn't care and she started to buy
halal meat when she cooks for me and
what so Allah made it easy in that way
and Allah also made it like so that's
the food part it's not really that
difficult yeah my parents Allah that's
that's beautiful man may Allah bless you
and your whole and guide them all to
Islam and allow you to be the to bring
them to
Islam I mean I know that one thing's for
sure that anytime we have reverts on the
channel and you know you go on YouTube
you see these revert stories convert
stories different ethnicities it's kind
of like it gives you that one push you
know at least I I can't you know
sympathize I'm not a I wasn't born as a
non-muslim but if I was born as a
non-muslim and let's say I was for all
intents and purposes if I was I don't
know bro if I was Viet enemies and I saw
a video saying you know some some guy
revers Islam someone else revers Islam
i' be like whatever but then I'll see
Vietnamese man revers toam I'll be like
okay there's no way we don't we don't
really do that you know we don't really
do that and then I see the video and I'm
like Subhan Allah it's one of us and
then it'll it'll you know obviously here
that is from Allah alone even if
everyone in the world is against you but
that might be that push that someone
needs to like normalize that you get
what I mean that's why like look at this
whole craze with like like white women
and white men now you know blonde hair
blue eyes they don't care cuz Once Upon
a Time perhaps it was unorthodox now
it's the norm you
know you think people actually think
that maybe I don't know with what I
mean oh this guy's Chinese I could be I
could be Muslim as well no I don't as a
yeah as a as a non-muslim as a as a born
Muslim that's imagining being a
non-muslim I I genuinely see that to be
the case it's it's cuz often times
unfortunately we we don't like to admit
this many times but we are you know
creatures of group think we fall victim
to what people think you know Subhan
Allah almost to the point where it's
like sometimes we have to have that lone
denter to say the things that everyone
else is thinking of in the room but
nobody else you know had the courage to
bring it up yeah and I think it's less
about it being a vocalized conscious
thought and more about it just being um
you know normalized it's not vocalized
it's normalized so you see it and just
in the back of your head you're like
it's possible opens up a reality there's
so many things where just from the
get-go we're like that's not possible
that's not happening some things that
are true like a square circle that's
just not happening but then some things
like me being rich that's not possible
so they shut off all possibilities of it
just because of the way they were raised
or what they used to think
subconsciously but once they see
something that begs you know to differ
or some kind of evidence that points in
the direction of you know it is actually
possible then it forces their brain to
kind of reconsider what it once believed
maybe that's why so many people are
being are coming to Islam through what's
happening abroad the conflict that's
happening in fastin because they think
to themselves oh they're probably going
through hardship like a breakup or they
got no money and they're thinking oh I
can never get out of this dark hole yet
they're seeing all these children in
festine suffering immensely yet they're
still happy so maybe they're like it is
possible for me to you know keep a smile
on my face through these Hard Times Etc
yeah amazing Point that's an amazing
Point um brother Muhammad he asked who
is your favorite or reciter mine is
brother
fat seeric and Muhammad you should also
let your parents listen or react to
Quran recitation also especially um
stuff like the part inah I think he
maybe he means the stuff
by favorite Ki
um I like that sudin guy maren he's
amazing that guy is you know what I'm
talking about yabi I don't know I don't
know he's that search him up search up
yabi and then let me know if it's oh he
passed away yeah he he passed away in a
car accident I'll find I'll find it but
this I've listened to the the whole
Quran like I've listen like if you see
it's this guy this guy can you see it's
like norin Muhammad sadik okay he's
amazing because when he recites it's
like I want to recite back to him that
makes sense he's he's so you have to
listen to it and when when he recites
there's so much emotion and everything
he says is so powerful he's my favorite
but my second favorite is probably like
Omar om is that say his name I don't
know how to say his
name yeah om that's it I see I see very
peaceful very peaceful very control very
like relaxing you know bro I'm going to
I'm going to text you a recitation after
the podcast is done this was sent to me
by Ramy about two or three years ago and
one is it the Indonesian brother or
Malaysian brother Malayan Sim bahanan or
whatever yeah beautiful brother preserve
him also um um one who I think manur is
is amazing as well as um as I think this
uh brother or sister said another one
who I think is is is very he's amazing
but I don't think he's very well known
for some reason is um
Salman I like his recitation for me is
is top tier above everyone else I like
something that sounds a little more
impactful rather than something that's
just you know soft and mellow so that's
just me you know my own subjective
opinion but I'll send that to you as
well in because I
love Spotify Spotify Spotify okay Amar
asks or says I'm grateful to Allah for
you being Muslim alhamdulillah I don't
hang around you but you got me gripped
with happiness Al
Dr mgl ask is Chinese easy to learn yeah
learn it start learning it but to be
fair that was my first language but it's
not that hard I heard I heard that that
Chinese or or Mandarin is is one of the
hardest Lang learn in the world do you
know what it is in Chinese there's no
alphabet so if you don't know the word
you don't know it okay you know you so
there's the there's hundreds of
thousands of words if you don't know the
word you don't know it and that's why I
believe why Chinese people are so
intelligent because they have to
memorize they have to actively use their
frontal like the frontal Lo and the
hippocampus to memorize all of these
words wow because in English like put
some letters together you can make a
word in China you can't in China there's
a specific order and it's a specific way
you write it for every single character
so so so what's the difference between a
letter in a character cuz I seen Chinese
writing before what is that there's no
letters in Mandarin there's just
characters there's just there's no no
there yeah there's no letters there's
just characters so there's just
literally words there's just words
there's no alphabet there's grammar the
grammar is really hard to
understand
wow well it's okay I'm listen I'm not
going to learn Chinese till I learn I
learn Arabic at least first I feel like
be the biggest L learning any language
that's not Arabic as a Muslim
first Oh My My Heart
mans right for me it was nice and
interesting to find out you were Muslim
and I think especially you being young
and Chinese it is different and people
might look at you in a way of
Fascination Subhan
Allah that's the beauty of Islam man
like that's why when I go to the Masjid
and you know I see a lot of these
brothers coming in with like a full
sleeve of tattoos and a lot of the older
Generations they don't understand these
things perhaps they might judge like why
are you a Muslim and you're getting
tattoos you don't it's Haram bro you
don't think he knows it's Haram and he's
he's like the F the first thought that
comes into your mind is why did he
intentionally arrogantly not ignorantly
get tattoos not the fact that what if
he's a revert and there's a I
think he said that if you see alcohol on
the beard of your brother assume someone
spilled it on him not that he was
drinking 77 excuses or 99
excuses 77 excuses for your bra yeah
Subhan
Allah Muhammad ask how did it feel
during doing your first prayer in a
Majid I caught it was it was amazing it
was I didn't know what I was doing it
was
amazing it
was okay the first time I went into a
mosque I watched everyone pray and that
that's when I already knew I wanted to
be a Muslim and that was amazing in the
way where everyone was moving together
and everyone had the same purpose your
purp you're not there to eat you're not
there to see your friends you're there
to pray to Allah at the end of the day
you know so that was beautiful for me
and when I turned Muslim and then I
prayed it was even better because you're
just locked in as soon as you lift your
hands up like that you're just locked in
you're just zoned in you're like oh my
days Allah is in front of you right now
you know and especially in a Masjid with
everyone around you and everywhere
you're all doing the same thing you feel
like a spiritual connection to everyone
around you because you're all there for
the same purpose does that make sense I
feel like too much no bro you're good
you're good it's a beautiful answer
you're absolutely right I mean just like
JMA yesterday that's exactly how I felt
yeah um you're just all in unison and
sometimes this might be weirdly specific
so if it is just you know yeah like put
it to the side but thank you one of the
one of the things that I noticed is when
I'm so in sync with the people beside me
that we actually move at the same Pace
like we go in R together come up
together you know this together
everything it's just like it's it feels
good and I think
that that how it's supposed to be really
like I don't want anyone to be too
specific about it any but like we're
supposed that's why we pray together
that's why we all do the same movements
that's why we all are supposed to uh
pray in the same manner we're supposed
to like if someone were to look at us
they'd think like we're an army except
we're we're an army of worshippers at
this point
alhamdulillah bro UK tour we got to meet
up in person man and just because I know
the Vibes Vibes are about to be
immaculate we got to meet the brothers
inshah how far are you from
hro I can I'll drive I'll drive to
you out of curiosity how far am i it
depends my
I have a I'm staying I can stay
somewhere right next to he like
literally I'm talking 10 minute drive
but where you are right now just out of
curiosity right now I'm in South London
so hour hour drive not too bad okay okay
not that bad when you come just message
me I can't pick you up bro I'll take you
to that the
restaurants bro looking forward to it
mesage g writes did you have any bad
experience when people found out you
were
Muslim yall really want know everything
yeah I did have a bad experience but
before I answer that question I just
want to specify the amount of love that
I got shown heavily like significantly
outweigh the amount of hate that I got
you know I'm talking about like a
million to one and the few instances
where I did experience you know hate was
from ex Muslims like I'm not even joking
I can go in my DMs right my DMs right
now and find ex-muslims that have
messaging me like I'm going to explain
to you why is not true and you know
stuff like that but that's the only hate
that I've gotten yeah some people be
like oh why did you do that but then I
just explain to them oh I've done this
because of the feeling that I feel
inside and how happy it makes me and how
content I am and they just understand
nothing really like no one's pouring
acid on me or nothing alhamdulillah so
yeah that's it really alhamdulillah do
you think that you would have had this
level of conviction in Islam if you
didn't have that communal
aspect would you can you expand on that
if you didn't have that level of
Brotherhood let's say like for whatever
reason the hate outweighed the love yeah
do you think you would be as as strong
of a Muslim as you are today or was it
that crucial Allah I don't know at the
end of the day I still had I still had
the faith in my heart you know but I'll
tell you a funny thing um an ex-muslim
messaged me literally today Subhan Allah
W and he said to me he was like I'm not
going to I'm don't want to expose anyone
but I'm not going to say his name or
anything but
he left Islam due to the hate that he
received
so I can sit here and be like yeah my
faith is crazy strong like yeah at the
end of the day I don't know what what I
would have done I would like to believe
that I would have stayed by all means I
would love to be like yeah my I would
have stayed in Islam which I I do
believe I would have stayed in Islam
because nothing can break my my belief
in God and nothing can disrupt my vision
of the beauty of Islam but Allah I I
don't know I don't think on the topic
why do you think uh obviously everything
is a case by case Nuance but why do you
think a lot of people that do
unfortunately leave Islam leave it what
do you think the real cause is the hate
it like the amount of messages I get
from non-muslims that is just like n
like it's the hate and also the
propaganda from the social media because
if you don't do your research and you
hear Muslims in Afghanistan have
prohibited woman from going to school
you're going to think oh Islam prohibits
woman from going to school but no woman
education
is what's that word I'm looking for
education is obligatory for women in
Islam I don't know I can't right
knowledge is men and women yeah that's
it that's it so then you hear like
that's the propaganda side of it oh
they're hearing all these negative
things about Muslims oh Hamas are
killing Muslim terrorists in festine are
doing crazy stuff I'm not going to say
the word my fault if I get you
demonetized but crazy stuff like they're
doing crazy stuff and so then they don't
and I reckon they just don't do enough
of their own research they don't really
sit down and think okay cool what's the
core of the problem what's actually
going on let me look at the individuals
and let me do my own research yeah
that's like the propaganda side of it
the other side of it is the hate I can't
lie to I get a lot of hate like every
day not I'm not looking for sympathy I'm
just saying I just get a lot of hate
that's just how it is and I feel like
alhamdulillah Allah bless me with a head
where I can just block it out I just
look at the positive of it when I first
started Tik Tok I did concentrate on the
hate a lot and it did get to me but now
aldah I just block it out but I feel
like some people it would get to some
people more and that would kind of drive
them out of the religion I feel I spoke
so fast no no no I got it bro there's
there's also an unspoken element at
least it's unrecognized in the um today
that a lot of reverts they have this one
I guess or even born Muslims there's one
thing that's like enough like a desire
of them and it's something that they
love and they just can't give that up
you get what I mean and they'll find
find theith mentioning it's Haram okay I
get it Allah does not expect Perfection
Allah expects progress especially if
you're coming from a life of sin or J or
just heedlessness or ignorance so we're
not trying to make Islam harder for you
than it has to be and we're also not
justifying you know doing sins knowingly
but if you have to be gradual and you
eventually give it up it's better than
you burning out and then just going back
to Jia and just leaving Islam altogether
obviously so this being said understand
that there could be one thing
emotionally that you just don't like
such as something that you like eating
or something you like drinking or
something you like smoking or something
you like watching or things you like
doing and unfortunately you know for you
that's your test that's your struggle
and because it's Haram Shan will come to
you and try to make you watch all these
David wood videos and apos videos you
know contradictions in the Quran just to
rationally give yourself that dissonance
that you know what okay I can sleep at
night knowing as s is false but it's not
is just the fact that you have this one
thing that's a bias in your mind and
like people aren't aware of these things
man like we we need to be more
empathetic with the revers that you know
we're not going to expect you to become
a perfect practicing Muslim overnight
when born Muslims aren't even perfect
practicing Muslims maybe even in in
their entire
life I like I like how you said about
rationality because I feel like Islam
wellit I'm going to go in a tangent like
yeah go for it go for it man I feel like
Islam
is the perfect mix of r
it because we live in a spiritual world
like I like you know when you can sense
someone's off and you got a gut feeling
and this and that and you can put all
your faith in God that's a spiritual
side of it but then there's a rational
side of it which is like the Miracles
and the scientific proofs and you know
physical proofs of Islam but yeah that's
I don't know I don't know why I said
that but yeah that's it that's it I
don't know why I said that no no that
was a short short tension bro Al lumatic
I was trying to keep it short in my head
I was like where am I going to this what
the hell aldah Ramy do you have any any
uh questions uh for this
brother uh none that I can think of
right now okay
aldah keep
strong anybody else that has any
questions inshallah before we wrap it up
let us know Rakim anything else that you
want to talk about right now any any
crazy stories recently I just want to I
just want to say um before we wrap
anything up please make sure that you're
praying you know for the brothers and
sisters abroad you know at the end of
the day they religiously yeah they're in
a better situation than us because
they're all passing away as martys but
the only thing that's really going to
change anything is if we pray for them
if we're actively trying to help them
because on the day of on the day of
judgment Allah might come to you and say
why did you not help your brothers and
sisters abroad you know so if you can
for yourself and for the brothers and
sisters and from the umra just and for
the um sorry just you know pray for the
brothers and sisters in in ftin because
they need they need our help right now
but yeah
that's aldah bro that was a wonderful
note to close it on I did have one
question for you that I've been
wondering how has being Tik Tok
famous I guess affected you spiritually
or islamically did you notice that it's
a fitna at times do you notice that you
have a following that gives you you know
shouldering all this responsibility and
you know things that you say
unfortunately people will follow that
too much uh or do you find you know what
no alhamdulillah I have a lot of
influence and I can influence people
positively what do you
think it's scary I think because I feel
like
well I feel like people have this
preconceived perception of me that I'm
this like Imam like they're like oh this
guy's B religious like he doesn't even
sin or nothing but of course I sin so I
feel like when I'm in public not really
anymore I'm talking about back because
I've kind of I've separated myself from
my Tik Tok if that makes sense I've
separated my personal life and
everything from my Tik Tok but before I
used to feel like I had an
obligation to be this perfect Muslim and
I did have a a toll on me because of the
pressure because obviously the shayon
would whisper to me and say I do this
and do that and I'd be like oh I really
can't do it which I guess it's kind of a
good thing but with the influence thing
I don't think I have influence on people
I feel like people like let's say if I
was like oh everyone go donate to this
bio I don't think that's influence I
think that's just people being good
human beings and they want to do it
individually and their intention is pure
so I don't I don't I don't know I don't
know
reallyy what do you think bro being a
Tik tocker as well um firstly I don't I
don't post too much on Tik Tok to be
honest I don't nor do I have a really
big following aldah but I I think that
was a very good answer I think there's a
lot of people that would have been like
yeah I built worked on taught even maybe
even groomed my audience to be like this
to be like that and all this stuff and
it's like it's it's a little bit
obnoxious it's a little bit too
self-centered it's a little too like
savior complex like you know I say do
this and they do that and you know I
hope there's no Creator like that out
there so I really appreciated your
answer for me
personally I've never I've never thought
about my audience as as as anything more
or less than just like any my brothers
and sisters people who can help me and
people who I want to help people who
like need to be made aware of certain
things people who have the right to hear
the truth of Islam and that's it they
like it they like it they hate it they
hate it I've I've learned I've learned
to turn tune out even the the good
comments like sometimes I'll like them
um or El I'll I'll go through the the my
my comment I'll look for anything that's
good especially with what happened
recently in ftin if anyone who supports
that and they put a positive comment I
will like it and show my support back to
them anything else that's talking about
me I at the end of the day like I tuned
that out I really sometimes I maybe it's
a bad thing but I look at the the
negative comments a bit uh to one keep
putting myself in check and two
sometimes y in that criticism there
there might be a bit of truth even if
they give you 10 lies they might say one
thing that's actually true that you
could do better that or that you were
wrong about or whatever so y that's
that's how I try and and look at not
just my Tik Tok but any any platform
that I'm on that is
amazing
all right Bros inshah if there's no
other questions we're going to wrap this
up Rakim where can people find you on
socials me um Tik Tok shen1 and
Instagram
shen1 can I can I give a couple shout
outs go for it bro okay shout out to
maram shout out to Har shout out to
anoir and shout out to Mariam and the
number 27 and that's
it that's everything what about the what
about the brother which one
the one that you mentioned did the sh
with you oh no I really shout he told me
he told
me preserve all these brothers and
sisters that are helping you know revers
like yourself and doing Allah's
work with this being Saidi do we want to
make a quick Dua at the end inshallah
may Allah first and foremost forgive us
for our slips or anything that we said
that was incorrect from ourselves Froman
may Allah allow us to continue to speak
the truth and Inspire us with the truth
of Islam may Allah accept from us
anything that is good and for forgive
from us anything that we do that is
wrong whether it is intentional by
mistake in public and private whether we
know it or not uh major or minor may
Allah accept our good deeds and forgive
our bad Deeds may Allah bless the people
in festine bless the Muslims around the
world forgive them for their
shortcomings or their mess ups forgive
us for letting them down allow us to
fulfill our obligations and our rights
towards them may Allah liberate them
grant them success allow them to
dominate the land so they can establish
the peace and the justice and the unity
that it so very very much needs right
now may Allah allow the to unite so that
we can establish goodness in the land so
that we can establish peace establish
the truth to stop the corruption to stop
the bickering the fighting the Bloodshed
the loss of life the loss of property
the the falsehoods flourishing may Allah
allow us to come together and put aside
put aside our different says for the
truth of Islam and unite under his
banner and may Allah grant us the
highest levels of jna and forgive us for
our sins and protect us from the fire
may Allah grant us the highest levels of
jenah forgive us for our sins and
protect us from the fire may Allah grant
us the highest levels of Jenna forgive
us for our sins and protect us from the
fire with that being
said we'll see you guys on the next
one
everybody May bless all of you
amen